out of the 10 main Straw Hat crew
members four have devil fruits Robin ate
the flower flower fruit this is a
paramecia type devil fruit that enables
Robin to quickly replicate and grow a
part of her body out of any object or
living organism including her own body
Tony Tony Chopper ate the Zone type
human human fruit Chopper is a reindeer
but after eating his devil fruit he
transforms into a reindeer human hybrid
Chopper has the same intelligence as a
human he has the ability to speak and he
can take on various different forms
Brooke ate the revive revive fruit a
paramecia type that allows the user to
be resurrected after they die for the
first time finally Luffy ate the gum gum
fruit which turns his entire body into
rubber or did he click the link in the
description to learn the crazy truth
about Luffy's real devil fruit